what's for everybody we're competitive
and welcome to another episode of
challenge from creamy people means the
series where you challenge us with
requests idea spirit to be able Venice
if your idea gets picked will feature in
our next video and give you a shout out
so make sure to leave your ideas in the
comments below
we're gonna find out if it's possible to
return orthos around the net shots let's
see how many we can return out of 10 can
I do the magic see it's 1 it is going
well okay that was a roller
yeah
[Music]
this challenge is from Anton 779 he
wants us to reach 200k subscribers by
the end of this year
and since the law you guys are
subscribers yet remember to do that so
Emma got four I'm gonna do five at least
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was easy with the hand Mohammed
Shahid wants to say a rally while
running five laps around the table Santa
say show how it's done
[Music]
okay it's not gonna hurt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's for one more one more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you made it wasn't ah no luckily I got
it on the first try
oh yeah so speaker Josh wants to do 20
shots in ten seconds that was ten
seconds here thanks for watching guys
hope you enjoyed this episode if you
liked it give it a thumbs up subscribe
right here and watch our previous
episodes here until next time